i wanted to alert you guys to an article
that's been written about conan o'brien
needs a friend
oh okay as you know i i'm not i don't
read my press
um people just sort of tend to give me
the gist
like oh you are hated or
um you dodge another bullet what's this
one well
you don't need to worry even after i
give you the gist about being able to
decipher
what the point is because it's from the
pledge times article and it's clearly
been translated
from another language by an ai or google
or something into english and i just
wait
can you slow down a little bit because i
don't understand what that means what
does that mean
i think that this article was originally
written in another language but
some kind of platform bot yeah bot
translated it into what it thinks is
english and when i read some of it
you're going to understand what i mean
okay this is great so this is a this is
a
google translated foreign article
about our podcast this should be
interesting
let's see if we can decipher some of it
so these are just highlights
all right identified for his personal tv
speak
present american conan o'brien
immediately makes top of the line
podcasts
on this planet
i think that's pretty good this is
fantastic okay what am i called again
american what american speak present
i am and i'm you know what i am an
american tv speak present that's great
here we go how what number of podcasts
are there on a dozen random avenue
customers
no less than 13. what is this
so far i understand everything this is
how my brother luke talks
by the way luke if you're out there this
is what you sound like to me
the provision of podcasts is so
overflowing that there
are in all probability an infinite
variety of high quality podcasts as
nicely
oh okay so what they're saying is we
have a good podcast
but there are so many of them out there
that are really good
it doesn't really matter which one you
listen to
your guess is as good as mine there i
think so many of your
good podcasts no no just so many
podcasts of high quality in general
isn't that what they mean
is that what it means i think that's
what it means right yeah which is fair
there's a lot of great podcasts out
there
who are we to say we're any better than
any of them yeah okay
i guess false modesty false modesty go
ahead i know all right
personally i've left and this is all one
word media amazimani
just one podcast which i pay attention
recurrently
it's conan o'brien once a buddy
colonel brian one's a buddy wants a
buddy
wants a buddy okay well
together with his assistant the second
presenter of the podcast
sona sonam obsession with normally
simply going through the stink
what what
i'll read that again i'll read that
again you only have to read the second
part again
we know what second presenter sonam
obsession and then it gets crucially
important listen
sonum obsession with normally simply
going through the stink
[Laughter]
well is it not true that you normally
simply are going through the stink yeah
are you the stink am i just going
through i don't know what you've
revealed
to this reporter you clearly had some
sort of
you think i spoke to that i think you
spoke to them and you revealed a lot
about yourself
that's insanity
oh good the producer of the present matt
gourley brings its personal addition to
the episodes
conan's speak present profession has
turned to the conditional aspect
he was close to the highest for a very
long time
popped proper on high and rapidly
dropped out of there because the
countless stupidity of the present
enterprise enterprise pamphlets oh
what does that that sounded like a burn
to me yeah it's like a sick burn
yeah i don't know i think wait so i was
i was doing well
yeah and then i popped out because of
the present
present
you were on top and then you fell
yeah but i mean we all know that but it
gets really philosophical here
following that apparently nevertheless
each wall
actually is a door as now conan makes
top of the line podcasts on this planet
[Laughter]
okay so i fell yeah but
uh and i encountered a door but then
that
i mean i encountered a wall but that had
a door through it
and then i became a podcaster yes and
that put me back on top
so you you failed as a tv host yes and
then you
thrived in the podcast medium great
terrific thank you for underlining that
so you failed you were really good and
then you failed yes yes
yes apparently yeah i i failed terribly
okay conan's peculiarity a weird mixture
of self belittling
openness to psychological well-being
comedian language
historical past fanaticism lightning
fast improvisation
and a community gathered through the
years of one of many brightest
friends match into an intimate podcast
format higher than another dialogue i've
ever heard
you know what i'm going to take that
that was fantastic
you know you know what you know what
that that that actually
for a second the computer became alive
because i'm so good the computer was
like it broke through and said damn it
this human is worth saving once yes or
that this is the moment that
skynet becomes self-aware and the first
thing it's chosen is conan
like no i think i definitely
i definitely think that was a beautiful
sentence in its own way and very true
and i do
think that i think the robots are
becoming self-aware
i think the internet's becoming
self-aware and the first thing it's
doing is saying
conan o'brien is a great podcaster
of all humans he should be the king when
we take over
isn't that what you guys that yeah
what i was gonna say was i think it's
really nice that all those things come
across
even though they don't seem to
understand english
very well your self-deprecating humor
your improv skills it's it's nice
i it ended up being is that it is it
done just two little
more okay can i just say uh
yeah i mean other than the fact that i
failed with my media pamphlets
but then when and he hit a wall that
turned out to be a door
i'm so far i'm okay with this review
this is one of the nicer reviews i've
ever heard
yeah and i think it gets better from
here um as well as
conan's fashion works higher in longer
interviews than briefly speak
present grunts i haven't laughed with
another podcast
as a lot extremely the head of conan's
profession is
outdoors of tv conan o'brien wants a
buddy on
all the main podcast companies oh my god
first of all doesn't this read a little
bit
like ee cummings yeah it's got like a
sort of a weird it's like a
there's a weird uh very modernist poet
it's got a little bit of joyce in there
it's a stream of consciousness kind of
thing
yeah yes yes it feels a little like
it's a little ulysses finnegan's wake uh
sort of teamed with an old modem
it's melting down because someone put
cheese in it
you couldn't ask for a better review
that's really good at times
and uh that's those are just selected
highlights so
that is fantastic that is fantastic you
know what i want
i want that uh i want that robot doing
my eulogy
[Laughter]
when i go and i hope it's not for a long
time but when i go
sona look into it i want
you know everyone to come show up and
sorry but yes the casket's there and
then they put
this computer up on the uh up on the
altar
now six feet under conan
[Laughter]
pamphlet in ground lost conan
live no more heart unbeat
clown foolish propaganda fell
now forever god's arms
holding food for worms i knew him
body moldering slowly uh
that's that's fantastic yeah that's
awesome death
auto erotic asphyxiation oh no
unfortunate
not mentioned press pamphlet secret
till now o'brien
with belt self choked
explains it photos under pew
in program for a funeral yeah
o'brien found old poster farrah fawcett
oh my god family not told
computer mistake just made
[Laughter]
you know what i'll do i'll fake it i'll
fake my death please that computer i
want a computer i want to see yeah i
want it to be like a bad
uh late 70s commodore early 80s and i
want it
i want it uh i want it dressed in a
black suit
and put up there with crappy old
computer
sad b.i it knows the secrets
oh and then it and then the computer for
some reason
it talks about me very briefly and then
goes into the
the embarrassing way that i died and it
goes on and on at length
for two hours because it gets stuck in a
cycle
and people like my wife leaves my kids
are ushered out
and it just keeps going on and on belt
used
[Laughter]
undoing sex was um wow incredible
that's fantastic i i salute you for
bringing that to our attention that is a
joy